tell me about sitting down to write this
book after our friend and former
colleague Walter Isaacson wrote an
incredibly successful and seemingly
comprehensive book about Steve as well
well my co-author Brent slender knew
Steve for 25 years and he felt that
there hadn't been anything that sort of
showed Steve's as evolution
appropriately some portraits of Steve
have tended to be fairly static like
he's half genius half jerk from birth
right and in fact he changed he changed
a lot and certain stereotypes that got
set in place back in the early 80s stuck
around for a long time because Steve
parceled out access very carefully to
the press brent was one of three writers
who really had kind of unlimited access
to Steve over those years the other two
were John Markoff of The Times and
Steven Levy and we felt that you know we
we had it we had a different kind of
story to tell about him yeah it is you
know Brent when I think of a Brent's
work at fortune wouldn't you were
editing him for some of that time he
kind of made a career out of writing the
Steve Jobs cover stories for so many
years and had that great relationship
but yeah and I think that you know one
of the things about Steve was that Steve
would regularly call a lot of reporters
in the early days and wouldn't take our
calls in the later days right right he
was he was difficult to work with and he
was difficult for Brent to work with in
some ways actually he may have been more
difficult for Brent's editors to work
with I mean for Brent he they really
talked about things a lot both for
stories and outside of stories that they
would talk regularly but he was an
incredibly difficult person to work with
on on on stories whose very demanding
about photography he was varied he you
know really wanted he always wanted to
be pictured for the cover holding a
device because it was all about selling
the device that is what he that is when
he would give you access and and that
was it he was difficult but he was also
he cared about
he cared that the look and feel and and
and quality of the stories would be as
good as the devices that he was trying
to sell so that's the journalism side of
that and we you know write what the
journalism part on that level but I
wonder you know the company's so
interesting to everyone in the world of
business who wants to find some kind of
inspiration for the way that Steve Jobs
did think and have the kind of success
that Apple is having in their businesses
and I wonder if when you look at what
the legend of Steve Jobs is it survives
it survives at Apple what are the other
pieces you think that are replicable you
know it's interesting there are so many
books built around the idea that you can
learn shortcuts to success from Steve
Jobs that it's about simplicity or it's
about valuing design or it's about being
tough on your employees the thing that
struck me most about about Steve's
Renaissance and the comeback at Apple is
that none of that is true there are no
shortcuts the only thing that that that
I can you know sort of advocate for out
of Steve's experience is that is the way
he trusted himself he he he learned from
everywhere he had enormous peripheral
vision he could that's what made it so
possible for him to go into the music
industry and into the movie industry
he saw widely and he brought all of that
together in in in side him and agree and
he was and he was an impresario who
could take all of that
and create something brand-new that was
two three four steps better than
anything that had been created before so
to me that's what's you know that's what
stands out about Steve Jobs is an
awareness a willingness to learn so
let's talk about Pixar a little bit
because Pixar was a business that George
Lucas couldn't figure out and this is a
guy who knows something about telling
stories and making movies and and your
book focuses or at least gives a lot of
attention to that that was so important
and I wonder what like what what did
Steve Jobs really bring to Pixar John
Lasseter gets all the credit for the
brilliant movies and I wonder what Steve
Jobs really brought on an active level
to Pixar well you know Jobs was
incredibly lucky with Pixar it was a
side bet that he made shortly after
getting exiled from Apple he his
original idea for the for the company
was all off he wanted Pixar's technology
to be both the basis of its own computer
and to go along with nexts hardware that
he was developing it next eventually he
became the negotiator and the outside
man for the company and those were
critical critical roles he was also the
finance to the company for a while later
I mean Steve's main contribution I think
to to Pixar was as this negotiator an
outside man he arranged he got them a
deal with Disney that led to Toy Story
he renegotiated that deal so that they
could have they were set up for several
more pictures and they were sharing they
were all co-financed
he he's responsible for taking the
company public and he's responsible for
fun eventually finding it a safe haven
with Disney and the Disney Deal you can
look at it as him sort of putting
Lasseter and cattle under the wing of
another guy who is really good at
outside stuff Bob Iger